in tonight's whatever happened to
segment democracy vouchers remember them
it was the city of Seattle's attempt to
bring more people into the process of
paying for political campaigns but it
came with some unintended consequences
correspondent Dan Springer tells us what
happened when we first reported last
July on Seattle's novel experiment two
publicly financed municipal elections by
giving registered voters for $25
vouchers to give to their favorite
candidate the candidates were scrambling
to qualify for the so-called democracy
vouchers the program taxes property
owners in an effort to reduce the
influence of money on local politics but
according to the Seattle ethics and
Elections Commission spending only
increased with those who spent the most
winning every time you can ratchet down
campaign spending limits you can ratchet
down contribution limits you can
increase transparency but money will
find its way in the new system also
spawned a whole new way to cheat Shelley
Seacrest who ran unsuccessfully for City
Council has been charged with fraud and
attempted theft her campaign manager
tipped off police that Seacrest used her
own money to make it look like she had
enough small donations to qualify for
the vouchers if someone's gonna go
against the rules I think that they
should be held you know they should be
critics also say the vouchers keep the
status quo and even in Seattle's liberal
politics further left socialist John
Grant worked the system to perfection
relying on a small army of volunteers
cultivated at the renter's unit in which
he ran to collect the maximum number of
vouchers labor back Theresa mesquita the
eventual winner also maxed out on
vouchers and received big Union
donations on top of that finishing third
just outside the top two runoff was the
more moderate Democrat business owner
Sarah Nelson it propped up establishment
it propped up the incumbents and the
wealthy and the people with volunteers
with clipboards but supporters say the
vouchers were a success giving some
political clout to even the poorest and
making candidates take notice we did see
Canada
campaigning in ways that they not
campaigned in the past we did see them
not sitting in a conference room dialing
for dollars but out you know pounding
the pavement the program is very
expensive candidates receive 1.1 million
dollars in voucher money but it cost
over a million dollars to run a high sum
for a system that did create many more
campaign donors but by the city's own
data only drove up the price tag to
getting elected brett dan springer in
seattle dan thanks